Marvel's WandaVision has finally wrapped up
the first big chapter of the MCU's phase four.
The grand finale left us with lots of answers,
several new questions, a killer costume change,
and a few great fights.
Let's break down the small details you may
have missed in all the madness.
WandaVision hasn't exactly been an action
spectacle, but its finale starts off with
a bang.
On the suburban streets of Westview with Agatha
holding Billy and Tommy hostage, the episode's
opening sequence sees Agatha and Wanda clash.
While it won't be until later in the episode
that Wanda shows what she can really do, early
in her battle with the older witch, Wanda
uses a trick she likely learned from fighting
Iron Man in Captain America: Civil War — rather
than using her powers on Agatha directly,
she taps into her telekinesis to slam a car
right into Agatha.
When Wanda approaches the house to see what's
happened to her opponent, she sees Agatha's
boots sticking out from beneath the car.
As she inches closer, she sees the boots are
empty.
The moment references 1939's The Wizard of
Oz, which includes the famous visual of a
house landing on top of the Wicked Witch of
the East.
Of course, unlike the witch in the earlier
classic, Agatha isn't dead or defeated.
That's not the only reference to a non-MCU
movie in the episode, either.
As Wanda, Vision, Billy, and Tommy face off
against the military in the town square, it's
a shot very reminiscent of the moment in The
Incredibles when the family faces off against
Syndrome's minions.
There were a lot of rumors out there indicating
that Benedict Cumberbatch might make a cameo
in the WandaVision finale as Doctor Strange.
Well, the finale came and went without any
sign from the resident of 177A Bleecker Street,
but that doesn't mean he was forgotten entirely.
As the battle between Wanda and Agatha moves
to the Westview town center, Agatha confirms
what many of us have suspected since the end
of episode 7 — the tome she was keeping
in her basement is the infamous Darkhold.
Before revealing the book itself, Agatha tells
Wanda,
"Did you know there's an entire chapter devoted
to you in the Darkhold?
That's the book of the Damned."
Ignoring Wanda's protests, Agatha reads from
the book, saying that the Scarlet Witch is
"not born, she is forged.
She has no coven, nor need for incantation."
Perhaps the most impressive thing Agatha reads
is that:
"Your power exceeds that of the Sorcerer Supreme."
As we know, Doctor Strange is the Sorcerer
Supreme, and he's not exactly a street magician.
The argument could be made that of all the
heroes to go one-on-one with Thanos in Avengers:
Infinity War, none make as good a showing
as Doctor Strange.
Of course, Wanda gives as good as she gets
when she shows up to settle her score with
the villain in Endgame, but still — saying
Wanda is more powerful than Strange is significant.
Of the many things Wanda does in her battle
against Agatha, she tries something we haven't
seen in quite a while.
Appearing behind Agatha, she taps into Agatha's
mind to uproot her nightmares.
Things don't quite go as planned.
While Wanda does unearth the vision of Agatha's
old coven trying to kill her, the more experienced
witch manages to turn the tables on her.
You can't blame Wanda for trying, since this
is a move that worked out well for her in
Avengers: Age of Ultron, when we see Wanda
use this power successfully on almost all
of the Avengers.
We get to see Wanda in a comic book accurate
get-up in episode 6, but, just as is often
the case in the MCU, that costume was intentionally
made to look pretty goofy.
Similarly, the costumes worn by Vision and
the fake Pietro don't come off like what you'd
expect to see the Avengers wearing while defending
Earth.
But while we get hints of it in the penultimate
episode, we don't get to see Wanda in her
new and improved comics-accurate outfit until
the series finale, and it's worth the wait.
We first see an energy outline of the headpiece
forming while Wanda is in Agatha's nightmare
vision.
After Wanda places the runes of power along
her Hex boundary and she accepts who she is,
we finally get to see her transformation begin.
Once she reclaims her power from Agatha, she
descends from the sky above Westview in an
outfit that reflects her comic book attire
— and doesn't look like it was thrown together
at the last minute for a costume party.
In his final moments with Wanda, Vision offers
words of comfort and hope, speculating that
perhaps — in spite of everything — this
won't be the last time they see one another.
Vision says to Wanda,
"I have been a voice with no body, a body
but not human, and now a memory made real.
“Who knows what I might be next?"
When he calls himself a "voice with no body,"
Vision is referring to his time spent as J.A.R.V.I.S.,
Tony Stark's A.I. assistant.
While he doesn't appear in person in the MCU
until Avengers: Age of Ultron, Bettany voiced
J.A.R.V.I.S. in the first two Iron Man films
and the first two Avengers films.
"Congratulations, sir.
You have created a new element."
Unlike his comic book counterpart, whose brainwaves
are based on those of the superhero Wonder
Man, Vision's personality is something of
a fusion of different characters, including
J.A.R.V.I.S.
That J.A.R.V.I.S.
helps to create Vision isn't exactly an obscure
fact.
But considering how much the character has
been through since then, it can be very easy
to forget that in a sense, Vision has been
with the MCU narrative since the very beginning.
By the end of WandaVision, we're still not
completely clear on what Monica Rambeau's
repeated exposure to Wanda's Hex has done
to her.
After she pierces the Hex boundary a second
time in episode 7, it's clear that she's more
than she used to be.
What isn't clear is what that means exactly.
In episode 7, we see her eyes glow blue a
number of times, and she recovers from an
assault by Wanda quicker than you would expect.
But in the series finale, we get a clue that
her abilities could be close to those of her
comic book counterpart.
In the comics, Monica Rambeau has the ability
to transform herself into any form of energy.
Particularly back in the '80s when she first
showed up, Rambeau would often appear covered
in a golden hue as she transformed into light
itself.
Along with allowing her to travel impossibly
fast, while she was in this form, solid objects
would pass through her without harming her.
We see something like that power in WandaVision
When Hayward tries to shoot Billy and Tommy.
Monica steps between the director and the
boys, and her eyes glow gold.
As the bullets reach her, they pass through
her harmlessly.
At the same time, the bullets are slowed down
— and Monica's entire body takes on a semi-transparent
golden appearance.
Back in episode 4, Jimmy Woo lists the Skrulls
as one of the possible culprits behind the
Westview Hex.
It turns out, of course, they have nothing
to do with it.
But that doesn't mean they were going to completely
keep their noses out of what was going on.
In the series finale's mid-credits scene,
the authorities are wrapping things up in
Westview when a woman leads Monica into a
theater under false pretenses.
The woman ultimately reveals herself to be
a Skrull and tells Monica,
"I was sent by an old friend of your mother's."
She tells Monica her old friend wants to meet
with her.
When Monica asks where, the Skrull points
meaningfully upward.
In most likelihood, the "old friend" the Skrull
is referring to is Talos, the Skrull who works
with Monica's mother Maria, Carol Danvers,
and Nick Fury in Captain Marvel, and who subsequently
has a mid-credits cameo in Spider-Man: Far
from Home.
It could also be Fury himself.
Whoever this old friend is, we'll likely find
out in the upcoming Captain Marvel 2.
If you stick around for not just the mid-credits
scene but the post-credits scene as well,
then you see Wanda in a cabin in some distant
wilderness — looking pretty similar to Bruce
Banner's hideout at the end of 2008's Incredible
Hulk.
Guarding the cabin is an illusion of a "normal"
Wanda, while inside the building we see the
Scarlet Witch's astral form accessing her
powers and poring over the Darkhold, presumably
to take Agatha's advice and learn more about
who she is and what she's capable of.
Just before the scene ends, we hear Billy
and Tommy's voices calling out to Wanda for
help.
This is pretty significant because in the
comics, while Wanda's twins are revealed to
be constructs of her power, they are reincarnated
in the forms of the boys who become the heroes
Wiccan and Speed.
While it's too soon to tell, it seems likely
this could be exactly what leads Wanda to
join forces with the Sorcerer Supreme in Doctor
Strange in the Multiverse of Madness.
WandaVision's eighth episode did a lot to explain the mystery at the heart of the MCU series --
namely, why did Wanda make herself the center of a strange, surreal sitcom?
Let's dig even deeper into some of the easter eggs and references in Wanda's real-life TV Land.
In episode 8 of WandaVision, Wanda is made
to see the night that her life was ripped
apart in Sokovia . Moments before a fateful
explosion, she and her family are watching
her favorite episode of The Dick Van Dyke
Show – season 2's "It May Look Like A Walnut."
This is a classic episode of the series, as
Rob Petrie watches a science fiction film
about walnut-obsessed aliens infiltrating
Earth.
The next day, all of the events of the film
seem to come true.
First, his wife turns into a space invader,
and then Rob himself begins to morph into
an alien.
The episode was a parody of the sci-fi classic
Invasion of the Body Snatchers, only with
movie star Danny Thomas as the extraterrestrial
ringleader.
The Easter egg at play is that this Dick Van
Dyke episode is really just a bad dream.
Rob's wife hasn't been taken by the aliens.
He's not missing his thumbs or lost his sense
of humor.
Similarly, Wanda takes all of the bad things
that have ever happened to her and turns them
into a bad dream.
Thanks to Agatha Harkness, Wanda experiences
a vivid flashback of her childhood in episode
8, and for the first time, we see the incident
that radicalized Wanda and Pietro and drove
them toward joining HYDRA.
In the middle of TV night, a missile rips
through their house, killing their parents.
Pietro grabs Wanda and pulls her under the
bed, keeping her safe.
But that's when another missile lands three
feet in front of them ... but it doesn't go
off.
The siblings stay trapped under the bed for
two days before they move.
And as the duo mention in Avengers: Age of
Ultron, the rocket has a very familiar word
painted on the side:
"On the side of the shell was painted one
word."
"Stark."
That spurs their hatred of Tony Stark, pushing
them into the arms of HYDRA as they volunteer
for the experiments that would give them their
powers.
Up until this episode, however, we'd only
heard of this tragic event.
But the scene in WandaVision goes into greater
detail, including a reveal that the shell
actually said "Stark Industries."
More importantly, Agatha questions Wanda as
to whether she ever wondered if it was a coincidence
that the bomb didn't go off.
"Did you stop that bomb?"
"What?"
"You used a probability hex."
From her perspective, it's obvious that Wanda
was a "baby witch" who subconsciously used
a probability-altering spell to prevent the
explosive from going off.
During one of episode 8's flashback sequences,
we see the Mind Stone float out towards Wanda.
As a result, she sees an image of a woman
in silhouette, with flowing hair and a headband
very similar to the classic Scarlet Witch
costume.
None of this is recorded by HYDRA's cameras.
What exactly this is referring to is unclear.
Is the Mind Stone seeing Wanda's future where
she fully embraces her identity as the Scarlet
Witch?
Or is it a reference to her heritage?
In the comics, Wanda learned only relatively
recently that her mother was actually Natalya
Maximoff, one in a long line of Scarlet Witches.
Whatever the case may be, this is the point
that Wanda first comes into her powers.
However, it's also clear from the start that
she's never had a good grip on how she's able
to do what she does, ascribing all of it to
the Mind Stone's influence.
It may well be that the Mind Stone simply
unlocked her own innate abilities.
After touching the Mind Stone, Wanda sits
down to watch an episode of The Brady Bunch.
In this particular installment, Cindy Brady
is having an argument with her brother, Bobby,
about her beloved doll.
As for the plot of that particular Brady Bunch
episode, the doll goes missing, and Cindy
blames Bobby.
The young boy professes his innocence, and
their argument spills over into the rest of
the family before the real culprit, their
dog, is revealed.
That episode is a subtle reminder that things
aren't always as they seem, and we can often
overlook the real culprits and create undeserved
blame if we're not careful.
In other words, Wanda is being blamed for
certain things that she hasn't done, and Agatha
is gleefully stringing her along.
The episode also has a slightly more obvious
connection to WandaVision: the doll that the
Vision uses to practice changing diapers on
in episode 3 is an exact duplicate of that
doll.
In episode 8, Wanda has a flashback to the
moment she visited S.W.O.R.D.
headquarters.
In this heartbreaking scene, she's led to
the Vision's body and allowed to examine it.
"I can't feel you."
Wanda's line is a callback to the Vision's
last words to her in Avengers: Infinity War.
After agreeing to destroy Vision to keep his
Infinity Stone away from Thanos, Vision tells
her.
"You could never hurt me."
“I just feel you."
Wanda revisiting that line at S.W.O.R.D.
HQ is a sad acknowledgment of the end of their
connection.
In episode 8's post-credits scene, S.W.O.R.D.
director Tyler Hayward reveals that his team
has had a breakthrough.
They've powered up the dead Vision's body
using energy channeled from an object directly
affected by Wanda's magic.
As it turns out, all Hayward has wanted all
along is a way to revive and control this
sentient weapon.
This revived Vision is a ghostly white, a
direct reference to a period in the comics
when Vision was torn apart and then put back
together by Henry Pym during the late '80s.
In the comics, the ghostly, barefoot Vision
was drained of all emotions for years, which
led to more than a few supervillain plots.
Will the same hold true for Vision 2.0 or
will it all tie up in a happy ending like
the plots on Wanda's favorite tv shows?
"Silly mischief that always becomes fine."
WandaVision's seventh episode — "Breaking
the Fourth Wall" — brings us to the late
'00s/early 2010's in terms of sitcom references.
Wanda, Vision, Agnes, and even Darcy participate
in talking heads segments in which they speak
directly to the audience, mirroring the mockumentary
stylings of sitcoms like Modern Family, The
Office, and Parks & Recreation.
While the style used in episode 7 feels most
like Modern Family, that isn't where the intro
comes from.
With its flashes of things you'd expect to
find in a workplace like computer screens,
calendars, and the I Love Wanda coffee mug
— plus the derivative theme music — it
feels a lot more like the intro to The Office.
Speaking of office comedies — just before
the theme starts, Wanda tries to laugh off
the bizarre things happening in her home with
"It's probably just a case of the Mondays."
That's not a reference to The Office, but
rather a reference to the 1999 comedy Office
Space:
"Uh oh.
Seems like someone's got a case of the Mondays."
The opening few minutes of episode 7 also
hide one more easter egg.
As Wanda-themed objects appear one-by-one,
a license plate with Wanda has the numbers
12,28,22.
Those numbers are a reference to Stan Lee's
birthdate of December 28, 1922.
Although the late comic book icon won't be
making any more cameos in future MCU projects,
the subtle shout-out makes it clear that Lee
is gone, but definitely not forgotten.
"Breaking the Fourth Wall" doesn't show the
brothers in their costumes, but the color
scheme of their clothing does reflect those
of their comic book costumes.
The green and white of Tommy's outfit look
a lot more like what he wears as the young
superhero Speed.
When Wanda gets her breakfast, she's understandably
freaked out about her milk's container transforming
a few times.
At one point it becomes a carton with the
picture of a missing child on the back, though
we can't make out the child's face.
Putting the pictures of missing children on
milk cartons became customary in the mid-'80s,
so it's interesting to remember that the WandaVision
episode dealing with the '80s, episode 5,
"On a Very Special Episode…" also happens
to be the same episode in which Vision points
out that Westview's children are missing.
Wanda's cereal is interesting as well.
First, the brand's mascot is a cartoon clown,
and at the end of the previous episode Wanda's
expanding hex radius changes the S.W.O.R.D.
agents into circus clowns.
Second, there's the name "Sugar Snaps."
It's impossible to see or hear the word "snap"
in an MCU production without thinking of the
most infamous snap of all — the one Thanos
makes to kill half the universe.
As a result of Wanda's swiftly expanding hex
radius at the end of episode 6, unlike most
of the S.W.O.R.D.
agents who are turned into clowns, Agent Monti
is changed into the circus strongman.
It's unlikely that Monti has been made into
any kind of superhero, but at the same time,
when we see a guy in a comic book TV show
in a colorful, tight outfit with a big S on
his belt, there's a good chance that means
something.
When you combine the S with the blue and yellow
color scheme, there are a couple of different
superheroes this could be referencing, and
both of them are super strong.
One possibility is the mutant hero Strong
Guy.
When he first joins the new version of X-Factor,
Strong Guy, like the rest of the team, wears
a blue and yellow uniform.
Another possibility, and a more fitting one,
is the Sentry.
Like Monti's getup, Sentry's original outfit
is yellow and blue and it includes an S on
the belt.
Also, while he isn't introduced until 2000's
The Sentry #1, it's revealed the hero's been
around since the early days of Marvel but
the entire world has forgotten about him,
including the Sentry himself — just as Monti
has forgotten who he is.
Understandably, because of reports that Elizabeth
Olsen's Wanda Maximoff will be an important
part of the upcoming Doctor Strange in the
Multiverse of Madness, fans have been theorizing
that WandaVision would have something to do
with Marvel's vast multiverse.
One of the most overt signs we receive in
the story itself is the commercial in episode
7.
While the same man and woman who regularly
appear in WandaVision's faux commercials weren't
around in episode 6, they return in "Breaking
the Fourth Wall" for an ad that mimics antidepressant
commercials.
The brand name of the medication is Nexus
— a word that has two meanings in Marvel
Comics, both of which relate to the multiverse.
There's Marvel's Nexus of All Realities, which
in the prime universe of the comics exists
in the Florida Everglades and is guarded by
the monstrous Man-Thing.
As the name implies, the Nexus is a gateway
to Marvel's other realities.
And then there's Wanda herself.
In the comics, Wanda is the Nexus Being of
the prime Marvel reality.
As a Nexus Being, Wanda reflects her reality's
defining characteristics and can alter the
flow of the future.
In the 1998-'89 miniseries Avengers Forever,
we learn the powerful Immortus knows Wanda
is a Nexus Being and fears the possibility
of her having children even more powerful
than herself.
He manipulates events to pair Vision and Wanda
off as a couple, in the futile hope that Wanda's
coupling with an android could never produce
offspring.
In episode 4 of WandaVision, we hear echoes
from 2019's Captain Marvel as Monica is resurrected
during the Blip.
We hear those voices and more again in episode
7 as Monica forces her way through the hex
barrier.
And this time, it seems clear Monica is hearing
them as well.
We hear the young Monica talking with her
late mother about helping Carol Danvers.
We hear Nick Fury tell her that she can only
follow the adult heroes if she can learn to
glow like her Aunt Carol.
And we know in the comics she does glow.
We also hear different people like Dr. Harley
and Jimmy Woo speaking about the death of
Monica's mother.
And of course, we hear a refrain of this line:
"Your mom's lucky.
When they were handing out kids, they gave
her the toughest one.
Lieutenant Trouble."
"You remembered!"
It's these words that give Monica the strength
to push the rest of the way through the barrier.
Piercing the hex barrier gives Monica superpowers,
though it isn't clear exactly what those powers
mean.
We see her eyes glow blue several times, and
she recovers so quickly from Wanda's assault
toward the end of episode 7 that even Wanda
is shocked.
In the comics, Monica is quietly one of the
most powerful heroes in Marvel.
She's had a number of aliases, the most recent
being Spectrum, and after she's bombarded
with energy from another dimension, she gains
the ability to transform into any form of
energy at will.
She's also had another alias that's been hinted
onscreen before: Photon, just like Monica's
mother's call sign in the MCU.
By the end of "Breaking the Fourth Wall,"
a lot of fans' suspicions that Agnes might
be more than a friendly neighbor seem to have
been confirmed.
Wanda's own suspicions are sparked when Agnes
leads her into her home and Wanda notices
the twins are nowhere to be seen.
She then sees a large, loud insect on the
window shade.
She asks Agnes where the boys are, and Agnes
answers that they're "probably just playing
in the basement."
Wanda goes down to the basement to look for
them, and we get the episode's biggest reveal.
This all unfolds like a tribute to The Silence
of the Lambs.
Toward the end of that film the hero, Clarice
Starling, believes she's just doing a routine
interview about the first victim of notorious
serial killer Buffalo Bill.
She's speaking to a man who now lives where
the person she wants to interview used to
live.
She's already suspicious of his manner and
some of the things she sees in his house.
But when she notices a large exotic moth,
something the killer leaves behind in his
victims' throats, that seals the deal.
She pulls her gun on him and he runs to the
basement, where they have their final showdown.
When Wanda and Agnes confront each other in
Agnes' basement, we learn Agnes isn't Agnes.
She's the witch Agatha Harkness.
We then get a montage of moments throughout
the series when it's revealed Agatha was manipulating
events.
It isn't clear, however, exactly what Agatha
is after.
Harkness isn't a villain in the comics.
In fact, at different times, Harkness has
been Wanda's ally and even a mentor.
While not really a superhero in the traditional
sense, she has surfaced every now and then
to aid superheroes during different mystical
crises.
So while it's finally confirmed that Agnes
is Agatha, we still don't know why she's there.
It also isn't clear just what she means when
she says it was her "all along."
Just before Agatha reveals herself in the
basement, Wanda notices what appears to be
a very serious looking tome shimmering with
crimson energy.
We're not sure exactly what this is, though
it could be the Darkhold.
The Darkhold is probably the most infamous
magic tome in the history of Marvel Comics,
sought after by the likes of Doctor Strange
and even the vampire king Count Dracula himself.
The thing is, we've already seen the Darkhold
in the MCU — in both Agents of S.H.I.E.L.D.
and Runaways — and it didn't look like this.
But on the other hand, it isn't completely
clear exactly what canonical weight a lot
of the Marvel TV series have in the MCU.
Whatever it is, when we see Agatha use magic,
it's accompanied by purple energy.
The energy coming out of the book, on the
other hand, is more red like Wanda's.
Also, the design on the book's cover features
two sets of adjoined rings, kind of like...
twins?
And Wanda's boys are nowhere to be seen.
Whatever the book is, whether it's the Darkhold
or something else, it could be acting as the
twins' prison.
Don't change that channel.
WandaVision is continuing to reinvent the
wheel for the Marvel Cinematic Universe, taking
the reality-warping series into a 1990s pastiche.
WandaVision's sixth episode — "All-New Halloween
Spooktacular!" — takes a leap over the '90s
to deposit us in the early aughts.
With its faux home video camera work and pop
punk theme, the intro to episode 6 echoes
the intro to the sitcom Malcolm in the Middle,
which premiered in early 2000 and concluded
in 2006.
The intro song includes lyrics reflecting
the bizarre events in Westview like "Don't
try to fight the chaos" and, later, "What
if it's all an illusion?"
Amusingly, the actual theme song to Malcolm
in the Middle, with it's "You're not the boss
of me now" refrain, also feels like it would
be suitable for Wanda's reality-warping rebellion.
Like Malcolm often did with its title character,
episode 6 begins with Billy narrating, though
his inner dialogue doesn't last past the first
scene.
Young Avengers fans are no doubt hoping that
Billy and his brother Tommy will eventually
grow to become their super-powered comic book
counterparts.
In the comics Billy is Wiccan, a mystical
hero and one of the founding members of the
Young Avengers.
Meanwhile Tommy is, like Quicksilver, a mutant
with the gift of super speed whose codename
is, creatively, Speed.
Whether or not Billy and Tommy appear in the
MCU after WandaVision, fans can at least say
they got a chance to see them use their powers
and dress in their — for the most part — comic
book-accurate costumes.
Billy's costume — which he wears throughout
the episode — is Wiccan's costume in the
comics.
Pietro gives Tommy a smaller version of his
own costume, which is not what Speed wears
in the comics -- but it's still fitting, considering
his powers.
You may also notice that just before Pietro
starts wreaking havoc in the suburban neighborhood
with his nephews, he and Tommy share a Top
Gun reference.
Episode 6 gives us some scenes between Pietro
and Wanda after the bombshell cameo at the
end of episode 5, and unsurprisingly there
are a lot of obvious callbacks to 2015's Avengers:
Age of Ultron.
Sokovia is mentioned a few times, including
Wanda saying her outfit is a "Sokovian fortune
teller" and the quick flashback to the young
Wanda and Pietro trick-or-treating in their
homeland.
Wanda mentions their childhood growing up
in an orphanage together, and after she calls
Pietro a bad influence, the brother fires
back, "who beefed in your borscht?" — with
borscht being from the same region of Europe
where you would find Sokovia, if it were a
real place.
Right after that exchange, the twins both
ask each other about the disappearances of
their accents — something Wanda slips back
into briefly in the previous episode.
And of course there are the references to
Pietro's death.
Early in the episode, Tommy teases Billy,
saying that his twin is afraid that Pietro's
a vampire — a creature who, possibly like
Pietro, is neither dead nor alive.
"You get killed -- walk it off."
At the Town Square Scare, Pietro tells his
sister he remembers being "shot like a chump,"
and later she has a brief vision of him pale
and riddled with bullet holes.
"You didn't see that coming."
One thing worth noting is that Pietro says
he was "shot like a chump for no reason at
all," when in fact in Age of Ultron he sacrifices
himself in order to save Hawkeye and a Sokovian
boy -- which seems like a pretty worthy cause
to us.
"All-New Halloween Spooktacular" finally gives
us Wanda and Vision in their old school Marvel
comic book get-ups.
Images of the pair in their half-baked costumes
were some of the first photos released for
the series.
Billy appropriately thinks his mother is dressed
as "Old Red Riding Hood" while Pietro compares
Vision to a traffic light, a half-shucked
corn cob, and a booger.
"He's what you call 'a manchild.'
After Pietro suggests he join Wanda and the
boys for Halloween, Wanda says he doesn't
have a costume, prompting Pietro to use his
super speed to put himself and Tommy in matching
outfits reflecting what Quicksilver used to
wear in Marvel's comics.
The silver lightning bolt is straight from
the funnybooks, as is the slicked-back, Wolverine-style
hair.
Does it look good in real life?
Well, not really -- but it's still a pretty
neat thing to finally see.
Some fans are understandably hopeful that
Evan Peters' presence in WandaVision could
be the beginning of the entrance of the X-Men
into the MCU.
While it's far too soon to say whether this
is the case, episode 6 has a couple of X-Men
references early in the story.
As the couple argue about whether or not Vision
will be trick-or-treating with Wanda and the
boys, Pietro steps in to take the synthezoid's
place.
"Big guy has a conflict, twins need a father
figure for the night -- Don't sweat it, sis.
I got the old XY chromosome."
Weird line, right?
For Pietro to mention his DNA and the letter
X is a pretty obvious reference to the team
Professor X built.
There's another X-Men reference that's just
a little bit easier to miss a few moments
earlier.
"The neighborhood watch is the only thing
that stands between the trees and the toilet
paper."
As Vision says his line, he points in opposite
directions and his forearms cross to form
a big, yellow X.
The ad for "All-New Halloween Spooktacular"
is perhaps the most bizarre faux commercial
we've seen yet on WandaVision.
The ad uses stop-motion animation and shows
us a boy stuck on an island in the middle
of the ocean.
A talking shark drops in with a surfboard,
gives the boy a "Yo-Magic" yogurt snack, and
leaves.
The boy can't seem to open the container,
and his teeth clatter as if he's freezing
even though the sun seems to be baking him.
Time speeds up and he keeps trying and failing
to open the Yo-Magic snack.
Eventually he withers away to a skeleton.
The ad ends with a shot of the Yo-Magic packaging
and the slogan "Yo-Magic!
The snack for survivors!"
The ad seems to be a fusion of at least a
couple of different brands of similar snacks
from the '90s and early aughts.
The packaging is reminiscent of Yoplait's
Go-Gurt, while the ad itself pulls heavily
from YoGo Yogurt, which used stop-motion in
its ads.
As for magic being essential for survival?
The message seems obvious.
At the Town Square Scare, a movie marquee
gives us a couple more Easter eggs, and like
many of the other references, there's a bit
of a time gap between them.
Westview's Coronet Theater is showing two
films.
On screen 1 is The Incredibles, which came
out in 2004.
It's a fitting movie reference considering
by the end of episode 6, every member of Wanda
and Vision's family has superpowers.
In fact, only moments after we see the marquee,
Tommy discovers his super speed.
Screen 2 is showing The Parent Trap, however,
which — assuming we're talking about the
remake and not the original from 1961 — came
out six years before The Incredibles in 1998.
Either way, both versions of the film feature
a pair of twins separated at birth.
It's an apt reference, considering how Pietro
and Wanda have been separated since the former's
death and how — in the comics, at least
— Billy and Tommy were long-lost twins themselves.
Each week, WandaVision reveals new and more
interesting layers to its strange TV-inspired
reality.
Episode 5 is certainly no exception, with
plenty of hidden pop culture and MCU references
When we return to WandaVision's strange sitcom
reality in "On a Very Special Episode," Wanda,
Vision, and all the residents of Westview
have moved into the prime time programming
of the '80s.
In particular, the intro borrows from Family
Ties.
Among other things, Family Ties is known for
making the young Michael J. Fox famous even
before he became a time traveler in 1985's
Back to the Future.
The most blatant pull from the series is the
initially colorless portrait that begins to
be colored in by a paintbrush controlled by
Wanda.
Family Ties' intro for its first three seasons
included a similar portrait.
It's a nifty visual allusion to the way Wanda
"colored in" the gray and lifeless Vision
that viewers briefly spotted at the end of
WandaVision's fourth episode.
"On a Very Special Episode" has its share
of '80s references.
But they don't all stay in the '80s.
When Agnes visits Wanda and Vision, she tells
them she stopped by on her way to Jazzercise.
Founded in the late '60s and still around
today, Jazzercise hit its peak in the mid-'80s.
We get another purely '80s reference toward
the end of the episode.
In the kitchen, Wanda tells Vision,
"Well, life moves pretty fast out in the suburbs."
It sounds a lot like Matthew Broderick's famous
quote from 1986's Ferris Bueller's Day Off:
"Life moves pretty fast.
If you don't stop and look around once in
a while, you could miss it."
But some of these references don't really
find homes in the '80s.
Early in the episode, Agnes yells, "Fussy
babies, meet Buns of Steel!"
The Buns of Steel workout videos, while technically
originating in the late '80s, didn't really
become a craze until the early '90s.
We get a similar moment when Norm references
a catchphrase that hit its peak in the late
'80s and '90s.
"What do you think Norm?
Should we surf the internet?"
"Cowabunga, dude!"
"Cowabunga, dude" is most associated with
the Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles, and, to
a lesser extent, off-brand Simpsons merchandise.
"Cowabunga."
"Huh?"
"Cowabunga!"
These blurrings between '80s and '90s pop
culture could be intentional.
They could be a sign that, just as Vision
is becoming more aware of Wanda's illusions,
the integrity of her dream world is deteriorating.
In the 2016 Vision comic series, Vision lives
in the suburbs with a synthezoid wife, son,
and daughter.
They also, eventually, have a synthezoid dog
named Sparky.
Not only is WandaVision's Sparky a callback
to the comic series, but his close call with
the kitchen's power outlet is as well.
Like the Sparky of WandaVision, the Sparky
of the comics initially meets a sad — though
much more brutal — end.
However, he's eventually brought back to the
land of the living.
Ironically, considering Wanda's decision not
to revive the pooch in "On a Very Special
Episode," Scarlet Witch is one of the heroes
who could bring the flying pooch back to life.
In "On a Very Special Episode," WandaVision's
strange advertisers are back.
This time, the ad is for Lagos, a paper towel
brand.
Showing Lagos wiping up an identical spill
to what the "leading brand" is trying and
failing to clean, the ad mirrors Bounty commercials
of the '80s that touted their paper towels
the "Quicker Picker Upper."
The name Lagos is a blatant reference to Captain
America: Civil War.
It's Wanda who unintentionally incites the
film's conflict when she accidentally kills
Wakandan volunteers in the Nigerian city of
Lagos.
Rather than calling Lagos a "Quicker Picker
Upper," the ad ends with the slogan
"Lagos For when you make a mess you didn't
mean to."
Fittingly, the juice that the towels clean
up resembles blood.
One thing that's easy to miss about the ad
is the reference to what's going on with Vision.
Just before the end of the commercial, the
husband knocks over a glass of beer.
The wife hands him a few towels as the narrator
says, "Husbands can use it too, you know."
This could reflect not only how Vision begins
to assert himself, but how episode 5 shows
he has a degree of control over the illusions.
For example, he's able to temporarily free
Norm from Wanda's telepathy.
This may also be why Agnes is so flustered
early in the episode when she isn't sure whether
she's supposed to hold the babies — because
she's getting conflicting signals from Vision
and Wanda.
And then, of course, there's the reveal at
the end of "On a Very Special Episode" that
will doubtless go down as one of the biggest
TV moments of 2021.
The doorbell rings as Wanda and Vision argue,
and after Wanda answers the door we're greeted
by a familiar face, but familiar in a way
that we don't expect.
Before we see the visitor's face, we see the
back of his head, which sports a head of hair
that looks a lot like the one belonging to
Pietro Maximoff — Wanda's brother who dies
heroically in Avengers: Age of Ultron.
We are, indeed, greeted by Wanda's brother,
but a different Pietro than the one most viewers
had to have been expecting.
Instead of Aaron Taylor-Johnson, who plays
Pietro in the MCU film, Wanda finds herself
facing Evan Peters — who plays Peter Maximoff
in 2014's X-Men: Days of Future Past as well
as the final two films of Fox's X-Men franchise.
As Darcy points out as she notices the change,
Pietro Maximoff has been "recast," alluding
to the fact that American sitcoms are famous
for their sometimes abrupt recasting of characters.
One of the most well-remembered examples of
this comes from a sitcom WandaVision mirrors
in its second episode – Bewitched.
The main character's husband, Darrin, was
recast when Dick York was replaced by Dick
Sargent in the series' sixth season.
Four episodes in, and WandaVision keeps revealing
new and more interesting layers to this strange
new reality.
"We Interrupt This Program" opens with the
first extended onscreen depiction of the Blip
— the resurrection of all the people killed
by Thanos' snap in Avengers: Infinity War.
Spider-Man: Far from Home lets us know how
the event comes to be known as the "Blip"
and some of the consequences of it, but this
is the first time we get a good long look
at the chaos immediately following the event.
Specifically, we see Monica Rambeau returning
from the dead in a hospital room where her
mother was a patient during the events of
Infinity War.
As Rambeau's body reforms, we hear dialogue
from 2019's Captain Marvel.
"Your mom's lucky.
When they were handing out kids, they gave
her the toughest one.
Lieutenant Trouble."
"You remembered!"
It's a fitting way to start the episode, considering
one of the biggest mysteries the story presents
is how the synthezoid Vision has returned
from the dead.
Captain Monica
Considering all the hints that have been dropped
in the previous three episodes, it's no surprise
to learn that Monica Rambeau works for S.W.O.R.D.
Her scenes with Director Hayward pretty strongly
imply that she was the frontrunner for his
job before Thanos' snap made that impossible.
But while she may not have the top position,
Monica isn't without rank in S.W.O.R.D.
After Monica's security badge doesn't work
at headquarters, Director Hayward shows up
and introduces her to the security guard as
"Captain Monica Rambeau."
The rank isn't an accident.
When she shows up in Marvel Comics, Monica
is a different kind of captain.
After obtaining the ability to transform into
any form of energy, Monica becomes known as
Captain Marvel, years before Carol Danvers
takes up the title.
Maria Rambeau
In the opening scene of the episode, we learn
that Maria Rambeau is dead.
From a conversation between Monica and Dr.
Highland, it's revealed that at some point
between the events of Captain Marvel and those
of Infinity War, Maria was diagnosed with
cancer.
When Thanos made his fateful snap, Maria had
just undergone a procedure to treat her cancer
and it was deemed a success.
Because Thanos' snap wiped Monica from existence,
she awakes not knowing that her mother's cancer
soon returned and she died three years before
the Blip.
But when Monica returns to S.W.O.R.D., it's
clear her mother isn't forgotten.
As Director Hayward leads Monica into the
headquarters, they pass by a number of portraits,
including one of Maria Rambeau with her call
sign, "Photon."
Maria wasn't just a high-ranking member of
S.W.O.R.D., either.
Hayward says she "built this place from the
ground up," which makes sense.
After all, S.W.O.R.D. in the comics deals
with extraterrestrial threats, and as far
as we know, Maria is one of the first few
MCU Earthlings to knowingly have contact with
any extraterrestrials.
Agent Woo, magical man
We first meet FBI agent Woo in 2019's Ant-Man
and The Wasp when Woo is in charge of babysitting
Scott Lang while Lang's under house arrest
for violating the Sokovia Accords in Captain
America: Civil War.
In WandaVision, he's the FBI agent waiting
for Monica Rambeau to help him with his missing
persons case, and their introduction to one
another includes an Easter egg from his very
first MCU scene.
In Ant-Man and the Wasp, Scott uses sleight
of hand to make a playing card appear out
of thin air.
Later, Woo has an important question for Scott:
"How'd you do it, Scott?"
"Do what?"
"The card trick."
"Seriously?"
It turns out Woo's a huge fan of sleight-of-hand,
and WandaVision reveals that he's been honing
his skills since babysitting Scott.
As he's approaching Monica for the first time,
he uses the same trick to produce his business
card.
During the montage that shows us the progress
of the joint task force investigation, we
get a couple shots of Agent Woo taking notes
on a dry erase board.
Under the heading "What is behind this?"
Woo has written "extraterrestrials (Skrulls?)".
We first meet the shapeshifting Skrulls in
Captain Marvel, and what we know about them
so far makes Woo's notation very interesting.
While Skrulls are traditionally villains in
the comics, Captain Marvel shows that they're
just trying to survive being annihilated by
the Kree in the MCU.
Captain Marvel and her allies help the aliens,
and in the mid-credits scene of Spider-Man:
Far from Home, they appear to be working with
Nick Fury.
So why would Agent Woo or anyone else suspect
them of something nefarious?
It could be that relations between Earth and
the Skrulls have changed.
Another possibility is that while Captain
Marvel seemed to imply its Skrulls were some
of the last the Kree hadn't wiped out, maybe
there are more of the shapeshifters out there
who aren't as friendly as the ones working
with Nick Fury.
The conclusion of "We Interrupt This Program"
implies that Wanda is behind all the weirdness
going on in WandaVision — at least, that's
Monica's theory.
When Wanda uses her powers to hurl Monica
beyond the boundaries of Westview and she
lands among the joint task force, Monica has
one conclusion:
"It's Wanda.
It's all Wanda."
The episode ends with Wanda and Vision sitting
down with their newborn twins to watch some
TV as the Jimi Hendrix Experience's 1968 song
"Voodoo Child (Slight Return)" plays.
The song is a perfect cap to "We Interrupt
This Program" for a couple of reasons.
While the word "Voodoo" can refer to any number
of things, in American pop culture it's often
associated with witchcraft, making the song
just one of a growing list of things referencing
witchcraft in the series.
More importantly, there are the opening lyrics.
Hendrix sings
"Well, I stand up next to a mountain / And
I chop it down with the edge of my hand."
Then, later in the verse, we hear
"Well I pick up all pieces and make an island
/ Might even raise a little sand."
If Monica is right and Wanda is behind everything
going on in Westview, then the imagery of
someone chopping down mountains and using
the debris to build an island is pretty fitting
for the series.
WandaVision is the MCU's weirdest project
to date, full of very obvious sitcom references,
and more than a few subtle hints that something
in Wanda's world is very, very wrong.
The third episode is no different.
Prior to the release of WandaVision, the last
time we saw Scarlet Witch she was tearing
Thanos apart single-handedly, posing for a
group shot, and chatting with Clint Barton
after Tony Stark's funeral.
That's where we left her in Endgame, but in
this show, her main challenge seems to be
in the realm of new beginnings.
While working on her nursery, Wanda unintentionally
makes the butterflies of the mobile above
the crib turn into actual butterflies.
This is a reference to a popular Marvel Comics
miniseries, and could even be the foreshadowing
for a character who has yet to be revealed.
"Kicking?
Already?"
"It's such a strange sensation, it's kind
of fluttery!"
One of the comic book series fans have been
comparing most to WandaVision is the 2005
miniseries House of M. In fact, Paul Bettany
has said WandaVision was pitched to him specifically
as a mash-up of the comic books Vision and
House of M.
In the latter series, Wanda uses her reality
warping powers to completely remake the world.
With a few noteworthy exceptions here and
there, most of the people in this new reality
have no idea the world's been remade, but
one of the exceptions is Layla Miller — who
comes to be known as, you guessed it, Butterfly.
Layla is a mutant before House of M, and somehow
Wanda's reality-warping gives her the ability
to "awaken" people into the knowledge that
they're living in a world gone wrong.
Nor do we think that this is the last time
Layla is referenced in episode 3.
When they're talking about what to name who
they assume will be their newborn son, Wanda
jokes about hoping "it's a girl."
Later, when Vision practices changing a diaper,
he uses a girl doll with blond hair — just
like Layla — in spite of the fact that he
and Wanda seem to be sure their child will
be a boy.
The episode also keeps up the trend of breaking
up the action with a surreal fake commercial.
Episode 3's advertisement pulls from old commercials
for Calgon, a water softening brand with a
line of bath and beauty products.
In the 70s and 80s, there was a popular series
of advertisements in which overworked, overstressed
women would throw their hands up and beg for
deliverance from the Calgon brand.
"That does it!
Calgon, take me away!"
After uttering the magic phrase, they would
be transported to a bathtub where they would
be overcome with comfort.
In this ad, a busy mother can't even eat her
breakfast without her kids knocking her cereal
away with a soccer ball.
A dog reminiscent of Vision's pet Sparky from
The Vision comic — minus the green fur — pees
against the wall.
Then a narrator asks her, "Do you need a break?"
"You read my mind."
Which is, of course, something that Wanda
can literally do.
The woman in the commercial is transported
to a bubble bath where a man in a Roman toga
fans her like a doting servant.
Among other things, the narrator says, "When
you want to get away, but you don't want to
go anywhere," which could be a description
of what's happening to Wanda and Vision.
He also speaks of a place where "your problems
float away," which evokes the way in which
Wanda makes things float away with her mind.
The mom, likewise, blows bubbles off her hands
as if she has similar powers.
Finally the product is revealed: "Hydra Soak."
The slogan is "Find the goddess within!"
It's a clear reference to the powers Hydra
gave Wanda, and the fact that those powers
are clearly expanding.
It's also intriguing that the product box
reads "Made in USA," since that's not where
Hydra was formed, nor is it where Wanda was
when she was given her powers.
If you're familiar with the hit sitcom Bewitched
– starring Elizabeth Montgomery as a witch
who both uses her powers to solve her family's
problems and struggles to keep her identity
as a witch secret — it's impossible to not
think of the show while watching WandaVision.
It comes to mind early in the premiere episode,
when Wanda is putting her dishes away with
her telekinetic powers.
But the similarities get kicked up a notch
in the opening credits of episode 2, when
instead of using The Dick Van Dyke Show for
inspiration, WandaVision uses animation reminiscent
of Bewitched's unique style.
It's a particularly fitting show to choose
to pull from for episode 2 for a few reasons.
One of the most obvious is the fact that both
shows deal with witchcraft.
Another is that just as episode 2 ends with
the world of WandaVision changing from black
and white to color, Bewitched began its life
as a black and white show in 1964 and changed
to color in 1966.
Early in episode 2 we get color mixed in with
the black and white, and it's as striking
as it is meaningful.
After practicing the magic act with Vision,
Wanda is straightening up the living room
when she hears a whirring and a bang from
outside.
In the bushes of her front yard she finds
a toy helicopter.
Unlike everything else in this black and white
world, the helicopter shows some color.
It's red and gold, with some metallic silver
mixed in.
The number 57 is on its side, and the S.W.O.R.D.
symbol is painted on the front.
The number on the helicopter isn't randomly
chosen.
The first comic book appearance of the Vision
comes in 1968's Avengers #57.
And once again, just as the Toast Mate 2000
reminds us of Tony Stark, for some reason
or another, the helicopter happens to be painted
in Iron Man's classic colors.
Like the premiere WandaVision episode, the
second episode treats us to another faux advertisement.
This time, instead of a toaster, we get a
watch manufactured by a company called Strücker,
and the commercial is chock full of Easter
eggs.
First, there's the most obvious reference.
Baron Von Strucker — whose short MCU life
ends with Avengers: Age of Ultron — is in
charge of the experiments which give Wanda
and her late brother Pietro their powers.
He's a part of Hydra, whose sinister logo
is visible on the watch face.
Aligned as they are, the watch hands can't
help but bear a resemblance to Loki's scepter,
from which Wanda and Pietro's powers spring.
Then there's the time.
The watch is showing the time of 2:42, and
if you're looking for Easter eggs in Marvel
media, pay attention to numbers.
Consequentially, 1984's Avengers #242 is a
pretty important one for the team — and
for Vision and Scarlet Witch in particular.
The pair are reunited when Vision's body finally
is restored after injuries he'd suffered during
a previous adventure.
Early in episode 2, Wanda and Vision practice
their magic act for the talent show in the
living room, and later we get to see that
act completely go off the rails when swallowing
a piece of chewing gum messes with Vision's
insides so much that he acts like a raving
drunk.
"Is this your card?
Is this your card?
… Is this your card?
In both scenes we also see what Vision calls
the Cabinet of Mysteries, equipped with a
secret door to let its occupant seem to have
disappeared.
Adorning the cabinet is a picture of the Mind
Stone stuck to Vision's head.
It's not just an Easter egg, but a meaningful
reference.
His Mind Stone was destroyed off-camera by
Thanos, and the Stone from the past was presumably
returned by Captain America.
The purpose of the cabinet as a device to
make things disappear and reappear might also
have some significance.
After all, both the Mind Stone and Vision
are things that were supposed to disappear,
but didn't.
At least not completely.
When Wanda and Dottie confront each other
in the middle of episode 2, the 1965 hit single
"Help Me, Rhonda" by the Beach Boys is playing
on a nearby radio.
It may seem like a song chosen just because
of the era, until you think about both the
name of the song and some of the lyrics.
First of all, there's the title — "Rhonda"
sounds a lot like "Wanda."
Then there's what the Beach Boys are singing.
On the surface, the song is about a man devastated
by his fiancee cheating on him, and asking
Rhonda to "get her out" of his heart.
But if you think of it in the context of Vision
and Wanda's shared history, it becomes a much
darker story, particularly with these lyrics:
"She was gonna be my wife/And I was gonna
be her man/But she let another guy come between
us/And it shattered our plans."
The last thing Vision and Wanda talk about
before being attacked by the Black Order in
Avengers: Infinity War is making their relationship
more permanent.
Then "another guy," i.e.
Thanos, shatters not only their plans, but
literally shatters Vision.
As soon as preview images began popping up
for WandaVision, it became clear the show
was taking part of its inspiration from a
fan favorite — but short-lived — comic
book series.
In early 2016, Marvel Comics released the
first issue of Tom King and Gabriel Hernandez
Walta's Vision.
The synthezoid had enjoyed a couple of miniseries
before then, but this one was unique.
This Vision comic also found its title character
trying to build an idyllic and ordinary life
in a quiet suburb.
Rather than being married to Scarlet Witch,
however, Vision builds his family of synthezoids
— his wife Virginia, his son Vin, and his
daughter Viv.
Unlike the heroes of WandaVision, the synthezoid
and his family make no attempt to hide what
they are in the Vision comic, which leads
to more than a few complications.
No spoilers, but here's hoping WandaVision
has a happier ending.
The style of the first episode of WandaVision
is based on sitcoms of the '50s and early
'60s, and the faux intro includes a funny
Easter egg calling back to one of those classic
programs – The Dick Van Dyke Show.
The reference isn't so much about what happens,
though, as much as it is about what doesn't
happen.
Fans of the The Dick Van Dyke Show will likely
notice the similarity in theme music with
WandaVision's.
They'll also remember that in some episodes
of The Dick Van Dyke Show, the intro includes
the titular star tripping over the ottoman
in his living room and taking a tumble.
There was also an alternate version used occasionally
where Dick sidesteps the ottoman.
In WandaVision's intro, Vision almost finds
himself making the same mistake as he's carrying
Wanda into their living room.
Unlike Van Dyke, however, Vision's powers
allow him to phase right through the precariously
placed furniture and deliver Wanda to the
living room without injury.
"Laughing at people in pain is a manifestation
of a deep-seated hostility."
He slips and smacks his head on the table.
Laughter.
There's a lot of twin imagery in the first
two episodes of WandaVision, usually in the
form of matching sets of jewelry, furniture,
and other objects.
And in some cases, the matching pair is missing.
For example, when Agnes introduces herself
to Wanda, she notices Wanda doesn't wear a
wedding ring — though Wanda takes care of
this toward the end of the episode.
There's also the two lobsters that Wanda accidentally
sends flying out of her kitchen window that
subsequently Vision can't find.
There's the couple's twin beds and other twin
sets of furniture, and even the matching pieces
of toast in the Toast Mate 2000 commercial.
Both of WandaVision's first two episodes include
a fake advertisement.
In Episode 1, we get an ad for the Toast Mate
2000.
Among other things, it gives us the first
indication that WandaVision could be taking
place in the same world as the rest of the
MCU, as we find out the device is built by
Stark Industries.
"The all-new Toast Mate 2000, by Stark Industries."
The Toast Mate 2000 is also a clever reference
to both Vision and Wanda's comic book twin
sons.
Vision is, after all, Wanda's "mate" — and
like the toaster, he's part machine.
The toaster, of course, creates two matching
pieces of toasted bread, just like Wanda and
Vision's "matching" twin boys.
And who makes the Toast Mate 2000?
Stark Industries.
Just like how it's Tony Stark who is one of
Vision's creators in Avengers: Age of Ultron.
There are a lot of allusions to witches and
witchcraft in WandaVision, which is fitting
considering Wanda's alter ego is the Scarlet
Witch.
One such Easter egg is part of the format
for the WandaVision show-within-a-show..
At the end of both of the first two WandaVision
episodes, the couple is framed in a hexagon
as the end credits roll.
That's not something commonly seen in sitcoms
of any era.
One explanation is that it's referencing Wanda's
powers.
While we've never heard them described this
way in the MCU movies or TV shows, in the
comics Wanda's ranged blasts are called "Hex
Spheres."
Not to mention that a "hex" commonly means
a spell or curse cast by a witch.
When Agnes takes it upon herself to help Wanda
create a memorable romantic evening in Episode
1, she uses tips from a women's magazine called
Glamorous.
Now, you could understandably assume there's
nothing much to make of that title... until
we get to Episode 2.
Wanda and Vision volunteer to be part of the
talent show benefiting Westview Elementary
and they put on a magic act.
Vision plays the magician and Wanda plays
his lovely assistant, Glamour.
"I am Glamour and he's Illusion!"
This is yet another reference to witchcraft.
While usually when we talk about "glamour"
we're talking about someone's attractiveness
or their lifestyle, there's another meaning
for the word.
A glamour can also mean a mystical enchantment
— in particular, it's typically an illusion.
For a perfect MCU example, think of Loki.
When Loki disguises himself as someone else,
that would be called a glamour.
And considering how much you come to question
the reality of what's going on in WandaVision,
that word carries some weight.
In the final moments of WandaVision's premiere
episode, we pull back from the screen showing
the sitcom to see a desk.
The screen playing the faux sitcom is surrounded
by much more contemporary technology, and
someone whose face we don't see is sitting
and watching the strange show.
More importantly, on the monitor to the left
of the TV screen — and on a notepad on the
desk — we see a symbol familiar to Marvel
Comics fans.
The symbol with the blade — as the picture
suggests — belongs to an organization called
S.W.O.R.D., whose acronym in the comics stands
for "Sentient World Observation and Response
Department."
The agency is first revealed in Joss Whedon
and John Cassaday's Astonishing X-Men run,
when they're introduced as the space counterpart
to S.H.I.E.L.D.
— while S.H.I.E.L.D.
deals with earthbound threats, S.W.O.R.D.
handles threats from the stars.
Fans have been theorizing about the MCU's
S.W.O.R.D. for years, and the symbols at the
end of episode 1 let us know they're finally
here.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
MCU Easter eggs are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.